hey guys I'm off the grid for August but
the Biden Administration is still
screwing everything up
Congressman this is your party I
understand it but does this help
Americans to put the IRS on steroids and
double their personnel
it doesn't it doesn't you know you look
at those numbers that you broke out and
the messaging that's coming out of the
Democrats in Congress saying hey this
will only apply to the wealthy we're
only taxing the wealthy well that's only
one to two percent of all taxpayers so
why in the world do they need 80 billion
dollars and 87 000 new hires in order to
go after one to two percent of taxpayers
their math absolutely does not add up
which should be frightening and
concerning because this means exactly
what you said they're coming after us
they're coming after entrepreneurs
they're coming after small business
owners they're coming after our middle
class hard-working Americans there's no
question about that and then you layer
on top of that what you just mentioned
their their Criminal Division with the
power of enforcement of a gun
essentially and how we have already seen
it's not a hype it's not a theory that
the IRS has also like many of these
other federal agencies abuse their power
to go after political opponents we have
seen them do this with lowest learner
under the Obama Administration there
were no consequences there and she was
directly targeting directly targeting
blatantly conservative organizations and
so this dangerous Trend that we are
seeing that happened gradually over
years but everything from the IRS to
Department of Homeland Security their
counterterrorism division the FBI the
Department of Justice we are seeing how
they are more blatantly in broad
daylight being weaponized to Target
political opponents of those in power
and anyone who dares to dissent or
question or challenge their actions and
policies do you realize that their
system is so Antiquated that I think
they were using Cobalt and they can't
keep up with the amount of calls I think
they get 1200 calls per second around
the country with people who are confused
about our complex tax system which keeps
changing do you know that out of all the
money that's earmarked for the IRS only
five of the 87 billion is for increa is
improving the technology how dumb is
that
uh it's worse than dumb this is
government bureaucracy at its worst
rather than actually identifying the
problem saying Hey how do we more
efficiently serve the needs of the
American people and and increase our
ability to deliver and serve them they
are taking our money this is money that
is coming out of our pockets and our
paychecks to go and plus up their force
and their ability to go and take more
money from us rather than actually
fixing the inefficiencies in their
Antiquated systems 51 of the audits last
year went after taxpayers who made less
than seventy five thousand dollars so
unless they're going to change their
Doctrine all of a sudden I'm pretty sure
that the average American is going to
feel the uh the scrutiny of the IRS in a
way that we're not prepared for nor do
we have the high price accounting firms
to fight for us for in many cases unless
someone Turbo Tax is going to help us
out uh thanks so much congresswoman
always great to see you Tulsi
thanks Brian